And again we compute the difference here which is 46,250 - 40,000 or 6,250, over 40,000
and of course, we have to multiply by 100 to make it a percent
and we get an answer of 15.6 or I'll just call it 16% error.
Now 16% seems like a lot.
This experiment like every experiment ever done in physics is subject to error.
Now the tricky thing is identifying and quantifying the sources of our error.
Now in this situation, we're really lucky. We have a known reference number to compare to.
We know the earth had a circumference of 40,000 kilometers so when we make some calculations and
get an answer that's different, we can immediately quantify how wrong we were.
But when Eratosthenes was doing this experiment, he didn't now that.
He had no idea what the actual circumference was and so what have been his benefit
to keep track of error as he was going along--so let's do that for this experiment.